I'm Jim Boggs and I'm the Scoutmaster with Troop 102 in Fort Myers, Florida.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by Packers Like Us.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
If you go on a backpacking trip, you want to know these two immutable laws of camping physics.
And that is is that level ground diminishes in direct proportion
to the amount of daylight left to find a campsite,
And the distance to any campsite increases proportionate to the temperature.
And in some isolated circumstances, the elevation of the trail also increases
proportionate to the ambient air temperature.
How about that? A couple things you didn't know,
But you've had it happen to you, haven't you?
This is podcast number 318..
Music.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Oh, let's take a look at the mailbag
Heard from Andy McDonald about the mysterious pyramid,
And if you haven't heard about the mysterious pyramid,
you need to go back to podcast 316 and give it a listen.
And Andy said: wow, that's probably your best podcast ever.
So many people need to hear this podcast.
Well, thanks, Andy.
I guess maybe it would be good for a lot of people to hear it.
I wouldn't mind.
Bob Lawrence got in touch with us.
He's from Boy Scout Troop 77 in Redlands, California
And he said my dad was a scout master in a camp cook
and a Navy man
And I made it to Eagle because he told me I would not,
I would not be able to use the car until I did.
It was a good move on his.
I owe a lot of the leadership and life skills I got
and used extensively later in life to scouting.
Well, thanks for getting in touch, Bob,
And thank you for your encouraging words.
Now, this is well. this really isn't a special edition of the podcast,
but it features the second half of a two-part discussion
starting in our last podcast.
But before I go any further, let me give you a quick reminder.
There's something I need you to do for me.
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
Right there on the homepage, up at the top in the right-hand corner,
you're going to see two links.
One of them says Support and one of them says Patreon- P-A-T-R-E-O-N.
These are two ways you can help support the blog and the podcast.
If you're a regular reader and listener,
or if the resources we've created have helped you,
this is how you can return the favor.
So if you click that Support link,
you'll find a way to make a one-time kind of a subscription payment
to be a backer for scoutmastercgcom and the Scoutmaster podcast,
And I want to personally thank Stephen Cray,
who's become a backer since our last podcast.
If you follow that Patreon link,
you're going to end up at something called Patreon.
If you're not familiar with it,
it's a way for you to make a monthly subscription payment
of $5 or more in support of the blog and the podcast,
And a number of people have chosen that as a way
of helping me keep things up and running here.
And I want to personally thank Jim Meister,
Mac and Catherine Barron
and Jack Parks, who've all become patrons
since last week's podcast.
Mac and Catherine Barron have a podcast themselves- actually
It's called Catholic in a Small Town-
and I'm going to have a link so that you can check that out
if that sounds like something you'd be interested in.
And I also want to make sure you know last week
I did not give a link to Mark Ray's blog,
which is called Thoughts About Writing,
Scouting and Writing About Scouting.
Mark has authored scouting books
and he is the author of the two-volume troop leader guidebook.
that's an official publication of Boy Scouts of America
that we've talked about last week
and we're going to finish that discussion up this week.
And our friend Walter Underwood joined us
and we had a great time.
We planned on getting together for an hour
and that turned into two
and the edited version was about an hour.
I didn't want to put it all in one gigundus podcast,
so we're going to hear the second part of our conversation
this week and I really hope you enjoy it.
And with that being said, let's get started, shall we?
One of the other larger pieces is the troop meeting program.
We start looking at that in chapter 10
in extraordinary everyday programs.
Mark, just outline what you would like to get across about that.
A couple of things.
We talk a lot in scouting about the summit,
about the other high-adventure bases,
about the national jamboree,
and those are all really, really great things.
but the way I do the math,
nine out of ten scouts will not do one of those this year
or next year or the year after,
And so for 90% of scouts
there's nothing beyond troop meetings, troop outings
and summer camps,
And so this chapter is all about those really basic elements
in the scouting program and how to make them extraordinary.
We put a lot of energy and a lot of time
into preparing ourselves for a high-adventure.
We promote it.
It's a very special thing,
but why isn't everything we do getting that same kind of attention
and that same kind of emphasis on excellence?
I'm making it something really, really great,
Especially troop meetings-
and I talk in here about the idea of a trap game
in college basketball,
which is that game that you're not supposed to lose
but that you do lose
because you don't give it the attention it deserves.
And I really think that troop meetings are our trap games.
We don't put a lot of attention into them.
They're sort of haphazard, slap together,
boring,
They don't accomplish their goals
and they don't keep kids involved
and interested in the program.
This is one of the chapters I would share with the SPL
and with the patrol leaders.
We know what it's supposed to do
or supposed to be.
We want that to happen,
but they're running the meeting right,
So it's pretty easy for it to fall short.
What we can do is both set the bar higher
with the expectations
and to give them a ladder.
Sure,
This is a great chapter.
There's a lot of good, actionable, practical advice in it.
I really love the idea of making everything as good
as it can possibly be.
Anytime you get together is a unique opportunity
that's not coming back anytime
And, to use another sports analogy,
a lot of times when a football team
goes to a really minor bowl game,
the coaches will say:
this is these players' Super Bowl.
And I think we should look at our day-to-day programming
the same way.
This is the Scouts jamboree,
This is the Scouts film expedition.
That's a great thought.
I mean, it all really, really counts,
especially when you're 10 or 12- earlier
I'm fond of saying when you're 11,, 12,, 13,-
you basically wake up in a new world every day.
You don't necessarily remember
what the last 10 scout meetings were like.
You experience the one that you're in very intensely.
One of the differences between
huge differences between scouting
and things like soccer or sports
is that it is run by the boys,
And these are the things that has to happen
over and over again. for
And if that's not interesting,
Scouts is not interesting.
If it's not engaging,
if it's not thrilling and wonderful
and something that I really look forward to,
I will probably end up finding something else to do.
Years ago, BSA did some research
and discovered that the number one reason
Scouts left Boy Scouting
was boring troop meetings.
If you go back and you look at
the big national survey tool,
the voice of the scout.
this is something that comes up perennially
in just about every single one of them.
The nature of the activities that Scouts are doing
on a weekly basis,
how much you're really putting into that-
it's just such a crucial thing.
One of the things that I really like
that I was able to include in here-
starting on page 58,
is a series of what I call
meetings in a box
or emergency meetings.
These are troop meeting plans
that a troop could put together
pretty much on the spur of the moment
when plan A falls through.
I think those are really good
for the scout master to have
in his back pocket-
or, it seems, collated to have in his back pocket
so that you don't default to
well. our plan didn't come together,
so we'll just get everything out of the patrol boxes
and wash dishes tonight,
Which try nots.
We had that dish washing meeting
about a month ago.
It's not that the dishes are not dirty.
I'm sure
I was quarter master.
Those things are vile.
This reminds me of,
geez, years ago,
Cub Scout Palwell.
somebody had a bucket with a bunch of stuff
and it's like: hey, den meeting,
we can do it.
I think this should be shared
with the PLC.
They figure out these five
and make two or three more,
Like counts seven,
Seven, okay,
Yeah,
They'll make it 10..
Sure,
Moving on towards chapter 11,
which is high adventure,
which every troop should have a high adventure program.
There I said it
Definitely.
And it doesn't have to be expensive.
You don't have to travel halfway
across the country.
Talk a little bit about the way
that you've preached high adventure here, Mark.
It starts by just defining high adventure
and, like you said,
emphasizing that high adventure doesn't
have to be going to
a national high adventure base
or hiring an outfitter
or something like that.
It can be something that's done in the context
of a regular weekend
camp out, perhaps
It can be something that happens as part of summer camp.
But then it goes through
a lot of the details
of how do you put together
a high adventure trip,
Especially when you're
doing it yourself and not going with
a high adventure base or an outfitter.
How do you determine the activity,
What is the planning schedule look like,
and so forth.
I can't really believe that anybody would read
this chapter and not want to make this
happen for their scouts.
Like you said, Mark, earlier,
what percentage of our scouts actually
make it one of the high adventure bases.
It's not a huge percentage.
It really gets left up to us
to make that experience happen for them.
The next chapter is going beyond
camping and talking about STEM, Nova
and the fitness awards.
Why build that in Mark?
Because I think a lot of people are not aware
of those opportunities and I think
there's another way to engage
scouts who may not be
interested in the advancement track.
and also,
as everybody knows from
reading the news, STEM and fitness
are major issues in our society
and if
we're emphasizing these within scouting,
then we're maybe proving our value
to families or to the community
in a different way.
Good overview of the program
with some very specific resources
called out here, too,
How to build them into what you're doing now.
Yes, and I think that's very important-
that we're not adding something
that goes against what you're already doing
in the troop, but supplementing it.
And then we're into
another section, right.
Chapter 13 and 14 are about troop service projects
and troop environmental
stewardship projects,
And this is a great outline
for getting those into
your yearly troop program.
Up until this chapter was written,
you would read: do three hours
of service in a rank requirement.
or you would read
in a merit badge requirement:
do a service project for
a park or something like that.
You guys know what I'm talking about,
but this really kind of dials
in on that. What was your goal
in these couple of chapters, Mark?
One of the big things I wanted to do
is some stuff on page 83 that talks
about transformational service projects.
I've seen so many service projects
that really were just busy work
where you didn't feel like the scouts
were learning anything. They might not
have even been accomplishing anything
meaningful. Service should be
something that is part
of who you are as a person.
I know that in the school district
that our unit serves
there's senior graduation project,
so a lot of these things have become
institutionalized.
but, Mark, you give some great advice here
on how to kind of make this
well. I'll use your words:
the transformational aspect of service.
Yeah, and you can plan projects
that are fun. Sometimes people
think service projects have to be
drudgery, but the project can be fun
and then that encourages the scouts
to want to do more projects
in the future. All of that
leads into in this section,
talking about the Eagle project. One of the
real pinch points with a lot of
scouts and four a lot
of scouts is that Eagle project.
so what are we looking for
in this chapter, Mark? Well, I hope
this gives a good overview of what.
first of all, what an Eagle project is
and what it isn't, because people get confused
about that. and then it walks through
the planning process. You mentioned
the guide to advancement, which is a great tool.
I think the other is the latest version
of the service project workbook,
because they've taken a lot
of the detail planning
out of the front end of that. You don't
have to have blueprints in order to
get your project proposal approved.
you just have to have enough information
that it can be evaluated.
Well, it makes a proposal-
actually a proposal rather than a plan-
Exactly, and then, once
it's approved, you can get into the
nitty gritty of the details.
One of my main things is
being the district approval,
the last signature for the proposal.
The things I tell scouts is that
you take the skills you've learned,
learn how to organize your project
health community- and say I did this.
There's five tests of an Eagle project
and one of the fifth one is that
the scout is on the path for a positive experience.
One of the things consistent through the 120 pages
of advancement policy is
the requirements are
hard enough, the way they're written.
adults are here to help. We are not here
to be obstacles. All the stuff in here
are things that I have. people have asked
me about. This is a
great chapter, and scouters,
scout masters, need to know about this stuff.
After I was
no longer a scout master, I finally found
at the back of the Eagle project workbook,
which had these this information on it,
Right, And it was
hidden away there where all the scouts saw it,
Right, It was ridiculous.
Yeah,
I mean, one of the
simple and brilliant things
about both volumes of this guide
is the fact that it harmonizes
a lot of disparate resources
that you had the hunt down
or you wouldn't have looked at
it always should be on your radar to understand
these things, and it certainly helps to have
an understanding of them before you encounter them,
Because somebody is going to ask you out of the blue.
Right, The next section,
keeping scouts involved and interested.
when I was first looking at this work,
I saw a keeping of scouts involved
and interested, and then
the first chapter in that section is
advanced advancement advice, and I said,
wait a minute, Maybe they made a mistake,
Right,
Because what is this doing in this chapter?
and then I read it
if I had to have a top three chapters,
this is one of them. One thing that's
helping people better understand
why we do what we do is
the guide to advancement.
You collected some of that thinking in here
and you really expanded on it,
and it's really an excellent read.
So tell us a little bit
about what you were thinking as you were putting
this chapter together. Well, the first thing
was to pull content from
the guide to advancement that
is often confused, that people need to
understand, like: what is
the definition of active participation?
what does a scout have to do
in a leadership position to get credit?
Well, and I like
throughout this volume, that
advancement is not a goal.
right, Advancement is a method.
It can be a personal goal for the scout
to be able to support that,
but how do you have advancement
as just part of what you do?
It's kind of the greatest hits
collection out of the
guide to advancement
It is. If the volunteers in the troop
read this chapter,
they will inoculate themselves
against the things
that just absolutely
sapple the fun out of scouting.
They will just read and understand
the why behind advancement
and then the mechanics
of some of it. It would
lighten everybody's load a great deal,
Because there are parents who are all worked out
about advancement too and again, you need to be
able to answer these questions. I think
this allows you to put it in context.
in the program,
That's the stuff that happens all the time.
One
really important way to keep scouts
involved and interested is to get
advancement right,
Is to have a good attitude about it
and to understand why it's part
of the program.
The next one-
this would probably be in one of my top three chapters
too: working with older scouts.
A lot of times newer
scout masters
and newer adult volunteers
will be working with
boys who are
15,, 16, 17..
It would be the first time they've ever dealt
with them. Yes,
It's a specialized approach.
I remember that
I come in and it's like this SPL knows more than I do
Really,
Because he was really good,
but I'm supposed to
mentor him. It's a little daunting.
This is not in a negative sense,
but they have a street smart
when they're that age
and they've been around scouting for a while.
If you're a callow or you're
reticent about
being honest and working with them,
they will strip the skin off your bones
in minutes.
Or if you treat them like they're 11 or 12 years old
Right.
That's kind of an advantage of
being a personal advantage to being a scout master
is that you have the tiniest bit
of preparation for your own
kids when they get older.
Mark, in this chapter you go into this
in depth, talking about
development characteristics of older scouts,
talking about middle adolescents
from 14 to 15
and late adolescents from 16 to 18..
What's the key takeaways here?
One of the key takeaways is
to remember that you're going to lose your older
scouts no matter what you do,
if for no other reason, because they're going to turn 18..
Your challenge or opportunity
is to lose them as late as possible.
The things that we talk about
under working with scouts and late adolescents
are so important.
You need to acknowledge
the young adults they're becoming.
You need to celebrate
everything that they're involved in,
whether it's academics
or sports
or dating
or going to the Friday night football games.
If you act like,
all of those things are unimportant
or less important than scouting,
those kids are going to vote with their feet.
I've never had an older scout-
14,, 15,, 16,,
17, 18 years old-
who didn't want to continue on in scouts.
Other things were happening
in their life that changed the terms
of what it meant to continue on in scouts.
I tried to do
battle with those things
at one point. You know what
Those things always went
When I learned to cooperate with them
and to realize this person
is trying to
become an adult
and they have lots and lots of things
that they're calling on their attention
and their interest.
The thing that I realized at some point
was none of them
want to just walk away from scouts
because they're not interested in it
or they don't want to do it anymore.
Sure, When I was scoutmaster
we had three or four guys
who were in our church's high school choir.
If they didn't show up to sing on Sunday morning,
the choir would be decimated.
So we made arrangements that
a car would come back from the camp out
Saturday night if they needed to sing the next morning.
By making that simple adjustment,
those guys stayed in. They all became
Eagle Scouts. They left
the program proud of their involvement,
Whereas if we had told them,
well, sorry, it's my way of the highway,
they wouldn't have made Eagle.
they would have had a negative view
of scouting for the rest of their lives.
Those very practical things
come out of an understanding
of what's going on,
what's happening in their lives
and how important it is to them.
Look at this chapter and you start
really thinking you understand
better than they do,
because they really don't know.
You should have a lot more experience
and a lot more understanding than a
14 to 18 year old scout.
We live through it, Mostly without scars.
Well, okay, scars,
Scars.
I talked about true personalities
and one of the things about our troop
is that
you're never going to be the source
of pressure in your life.
We just don't do that.
What a good thought.
You're here because you want to be here,
because it's fun. Nearly everybody
who gets life rank gets Eagle.
There's like a handful of people in 10 years
who haven't done that.
So we just say, man, there's so much
going on in your life
And you may be the only person
in those scouts lives
who's not putting pressure on them.
That's why it's a whole total
laissez-faire approach to advancement.
So here it is, man,
You can walk around it, You can jump over it.
You know plenty of opportunities.
Let's go camping.
The rest of your life is a little crazy right now
and I understand that
We will try to be the non-crazy place
for you.
Let's have scouting. be the non-crazy place,
That's another motto.
I like it.
Moving on to chapter 18.
here's another really fantastic thing
that nobody knows anything about.
in a lot of ways
that has been, you know,
squirreled away in different resources
and other parts of scouting literature.
But now here it is. It's right here,
working with the order of the arrow,
venturing and sea scouts.
So tell us about this chapter, Mark.
Many, many troop leaders
think that these other groups are the enemy,
That their intent
on coming and sucking away
all their older scouts just when they get them
trained up to be youth leaders.
So what I wanted to do
in this chapter was dispel that notion
and talk about, as the title says,
how we can work with them.
For each of those programs,
first of all, we go through
a really detailed introduction
to what they actually are.
What's the purpose of the order of the arrow,
What's the history, How is it structured,
What are the membership levels,
How do elections work,
How do governments get nominated
And so forth.
We talk about the OA troop representative
and troop representative advisor
and the OA unit of excellence award,
which most scout masters
probably have not heard about.
All of that really builds up to
harnessing the power of the OA
for your troop.
Now that you understand the OA,
how can you leverage what the lodge is doing
to benefit your troop?
And then we do the same thing with venturing
to the Boy Scout troop.
Reading this is like the FAQ
for these programs.
It used to be really difficult to find answers
to those questions.
but now here they are.
And why are these good things
rather than things to be batted away?
They're a way of expanding
the experience for your scouts.
I really appreciate the spirit
in which they're presented.
Oh, this is great, because
I don't know how long I spent
on all this information.
I'm really good at finding
things on the web.
I've been doing this for 20 years
professionally
And it was a lot of work.
So this just saved thousands
of people.
day of swearing at the computer
and giving up and not doing OA.
You don't swear at your computer, do you?
I do, but it's for
advanced
visits.
Yeah,
The next section. I really like this section
responding to special challenges.
Mark, tell us a little bit about it.
Well, let me read the
first paragraph of this first page,
because I think this really encapsulates
a frustration that I have long had
with training videos
and the Preview Scout Master Handbook.
Here's what it says.
Somewhere there may be a troop that looks like
a Norman Rockwell painting, come to life
with photogenic and perfectly uniform scouts
flawlessly carrying out the Boy Scout
program as Robert
Ben Powell envisioned. Chances are
it's not your troop.
Yes,
If that troop exists, get in touch with me
and I'll put
you in touch with Mark so he can come and study
what you're doing.
It's good to know that if your troop
looks like a hot mess
rather than a Norman Rockwell painting, you're probably
doing just fine.
We have a Boy Scout museum.
Let's put that troop in.
We could.
It's in Irving, Texas. I've been there,
Medically sealed under glass.
That is the only way it would exist, I believe.
Yes,
And so we talk about discipline,
conflict resolution,
counseling,
special needs, scouts,
underserved populations
and then what I call special troop situations,
which is
the very small troop
and the very new troop.
The idea of
discipline
and conflict resolution
is one that we don't have enough
discussion about, and you kind of stumble
into some things
as you move along if you hang around
long enough. but this is
just a really good starting point.
Well, this is the stuff that
you hope you don't need to know,
and even after it happens,
you hope you don't need to be good at it.
Right,
You actually need to be good at it
before it happens. Welcome to Scout Mastership.
Discipline problems
or conflicts or things like that
are relatively uncommon.
When you encounter one, you think that,
A- you're the only person who's ever
encountered this particular thing before
and, B,
that it is some failing on
your part personally, or
the part of your unit
or the part of the scouts.
and there really are pretty garden
variety things.
and understanding that
first step, which I think is kind of implicit
in what you read. Mark,
you know you're going to run into problems.
so here's how these problems get resolved.
hold your breath for a moment, count to
10, go through the steps here
and you'll be able to resolve these
things without causing any more suffering
than you absolutely have to,
for yourself as well as for your
scouts and everyone else involved.
Scouter from another troop
gave me an award after
just one week of summer camp
for the list of things
that went wrong, some of them between
his and our troop.
that
was capped off by our
commissioner puncturing a lung.
Oh man, Ouch,
Ouch, yeah. Well,
they're like heart attack. luckily we had a wilderness
EMT on staff, so
You win the prize on that one, Walter.
Well, yeah, you know I
not a prize you want, but
I wish I'd had this chapter, these chapters
Within the top 10
of questions that I get-
are dealing with very large troops,
very small troops and brand new troops,
and this is very,
very helpful stuff. Okay,
World troops,
I mean, yeah, this is-
I'm sure you've picked this up
from sessions of film on and just listening,
because this is the stuff
you can't get from somebody else
because there's not a small
troop around. or if you're rural,
500 miles to the next
rural troop, Sure,
We have this
image in our mind- at least I do
that the ideal troop is
20, 24 scouts,
3, 4 patrols, whatever the
case may be. but that model is not
the only model that's out there. There are
lots of troops that are one patrol size.
there are lots of troops that are
220 kids. Those
operate very differently and we need to
understand that And there is not one
acceptable model or
perfect model. One of the real genius
things about scouting
is how adaptable it is to these different
situations and just about
any circumstance. But the
big thing that changes is the
job of the committee and the scout master.
Right,
For the scouts
it doesn't change that much,
but the scout master needs different
strategies And that's one of the problems
that occurs when that
10 scout troop becomes
a 40 scout troop. if the adults
haven't changed how they operate
Right, It's going to fail. It's going
to go back to the 10 scouts.
The sudden growth scenario:
Yeah, I was
scout master. when
the large group of Weeblers joined,
the scout troop had been 23
scouts. We made it
6.. So a lot of what I did
as a scout master had to
change for a bigger troop. The
chapter on
underserved populations- and it's
not just what you think it might
be- Talk a little bit about that, Mark.
So this starts with multicultural
markets, which is
what people often think,
and there's a lot of good stuff in there.
but it also talks about rural scouting.
once again, the essay had
some really good materials out there
that we never heard of. that we were able to adapt Right.
And then there's even
a section on on Lone Scouts,
which is still a viable program.
I do hear from people who are working
with Lone Scouts every once in a while.
it's important to know that that exists.
it certainly is a great way to serve
boys and rural communities.
sons of migratory farm workers,
exchange students
away from the United States for a year or more.
everybody should get the chance to have
a scouting experience, and
that's the way it's going to work. That's the way it's going to work.
The next chapter
is working with Scouts
with special needs and disabilities.
Yeah, most of this comes from
the book that Tony made together.
working with Scouts with special needs
and disabilities, I think, is the title of that.
Our oldest son has
developmentally disabled. obviously,
I'm very aware of these things and the Scouts
really had scattered resources
about ten years ago
and this has really been pulled together. This is
a great chapter. We're seeing a lot
more awareness of Scouts
with learning disabilities,
offices of spectrum,
those kinds of things. You're going to see this
as a scout master. Is it going to happen?
Yes, you should
make sure that it happens.
Well, yes, absolutely,
individual scouting plan,
those kinds of things. This is a great chapter
and it's again one of those things
you just need to
need to have a
basic understanding of.
And also there's a newsletter-
any free e-newsletter
that you can sign up for- that we mentioned in the chapter,
and there's other online
resources. So this is a good starting point,
but I would definitely encourage people
to learn more. The last few words of this
chapter are: integrating Scouts
with disabilities into your troop can create challenges
that require extra effort on your part.
The benefits are worth it,
however, for anyone involved,
especially the Scouts themselves.
there's never true words spoken.
having the knowledge that
this will work, you can actually
do it. You're cutting yourself short
if don't have
a couple of differently abled Scouts
involved with your troop. It's not just
about serving them, it's about
all the families in your troop and
all of the-
oh- you never want to say normal Scouts,
because I've never seen one,
but
it's a very, very important part
of the program in my book.
Well, and it's a huge thing
for the other Scouts
that they've learned this
at a stage where they're just learning
everything, that they have
good models for this. You
interact with them. Again, this is adult
association. this is modeling.
Scout Masters need to be prepared.
Scout Master Corps needs to be prepared
to do this
gracefully And to welcome. it
is, I guess, what I'm. it's not
something to look at in the go. oh my gosh,
how are we going to do this? now you're going to do fine,
uh-oh. no, it's not.
no, it's a let's
go. Yeah, well,
we're at the end of the
chapters and then
there is a really useful appendix.
what's in there that we
haven't seen before. Most everything that
you see in there is pull from
the body of the book. so if there was
a worksheet or a
planner or something like that early in the book,
you'll find it here. But then the other thing
that's really useful is a lot of links
to some other documents that are
not reproduced here, as well as
links to a lot of websites.
We talked about Scouts with
special needs and disabilities. There's a link
here to the section on
scoutingorg that focuses on Scouts
with Disabilities- Any number of
resources that will save you looking
around trying to find things.
So it's great to see it all collected there.
and there's a glossary,
because we have Scoutspeak,
so we have to understand
who is a district executive
anyway. Yes,
Well, Scoutmaster
Corps- it's a whole new term, not the glossary,
but that's okay, I didn't know.
there was a special newsletter
for Meribatch counselors. There you go,
Counselors Compass.
I signed up for everything.
You learn something new every day. Yeah,
All in all, my
assessment of the second volume
is even more positive
than the first volume, if that's possible,
and this is really, really key. This
is great and people are really going to
appreciate this mark. Thank you for all the
work that you put into it. Oh, you're welcome.
I'm glad you like it.
It's that good. It's good enough that
it should be part of all of our
training in the BSA. Well, this is one
of those things that when you see it, you go:
okay, why haven't we had this before?
This is great,
So much like the Guide to Advancement
was when it came out. Oh,
this is going to solve a lot of problems.
Everybody get a copy,
Absolutely Now. well, no,
In July, June,
June, Late June.
I have one complaint with these two
volumes, and that is that they're not
available digitally. Whatever
pool you have with the powers that be,
they could recover all the costs that
they put into producing these in
a couple of hours if they made them
available digitally. I would gladly
pay the same price
for a digital version that I would
for the printed article. Yeah,
I'll pass that on. I'm not sure where things
stand because I know that it was
discussed at one point. Yeah,
Yeah, I tried the way to go.
I tried the PDF on
on my Kindle and it was
very tiny type.
Well, it could use. Was it working?
It could be very simply reformatted
to take advantage of some things
that are available in digital format
that you can't get in, You can do that,
But even just as a
PDF, the one thing that
I really count on with PDFs
is you can search Right,
Right. I really appreciate the
time you spent with us this evening, Mark,
and I'm looking forward
to seeing the general release of this
so everybody can get a copy.
Good deal, Me too. Thanks again, Walter.
Oh, I know you'll make me sound
smarter. That may
be smart, but smarter. Well,
I hire out by the hour for that, should
you need it in other areas.
That sounds like a plan.
Thanks very much, guys.
Thank you, Good talk with you.
That's the second of a two part conversation.
Go back to
scoutmastercgcom. look up podcast 317
to listen to the first half.
One thing I want to make sure to mention
again is that, according
to Mark, the second
volume of the troop leader guidebook
should be in Scout shops by the end
of June, And I want to
highly recommend anybody involved
with a scout troop, any adult volunteer
involved with a scout troop- get both
volumes and look at them
and keep them close to him. They're excellent
resources for you and your service
to your scouts. I'd love to
have you get in touch with me and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Music.
Well, thank you for listening to this
318th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Now here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email
and you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media. You can join
the nearly 14,000 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
We have a chorus of tweeters at Twitter
and pinners at Pinterest,
and you can watch us at YouTube.
but if you can't face Facebook,
Twitter tends to make you better
and you have no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the name on YouTube.
don't worry, my friend, that's right.
just zoom into the late 90's
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
you can get in touch with me,
ClarkGreen at Clark,
at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E
Now, if none of those
ways of getting in touch work for you,
write your message on a piece of paper
hermetically, seal it in a bottle
or other container and bury it in any
campfire circle. I'll be sure to get it eventually,
as I do have agents everywhere.
Well, by now,
it must be abundantly clear that
the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of anyone
in particular other than yours
truly. Now, we're not sponsored
or endorsed by the Boy Scouts of America or any other
scouting organization. it's just me,
and somehow I stumbled on
to how to get on the internet and have a podcast.
how about that? huh,
And it's my way of helping my fellow
scouts and having a little bit of fun. and
speaking of fun,
here is our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.